John Burke oh very good evening to you
have you had the opportunity to talk to
Julian Lewis since he was stripped of
the whip would you know how he feels now
I haven't spoken to him today I should
imagine that he's disappointed but also
Collin somewhat surprised because after
all the government had been signaling
that it had no intention of interfering
or seeking to impose a candidate but was
perfectly ready as the statute required
to leave it to see the apartment Ariens
on the committee so as Celia
parliamentarians on the committee
exercised their proper role and chose
Julian Lewis as the chair I should
imagine that Julian is somewhat taken
aback nay disappointed that the
government has reacted in such a
spiteful malicious and frankly really
rather petty fashion they had absolutely
no business whatsoever interfering in
this matter with it those are strong
adjectives aren't they I mean that there
will be those who also will hang on to
withdraw the whip in these circumstances
it's that the slack of firm government
if somebody's consorting with the
opposition to deny the Prime Minister's
will then consequences will follow
Collin you've got a job to do and you've
got to ask that question but it's
nothing to do with the smack of
government the reality of the matter is
that this is a nonpartisan committee of
Parliament's the Justice and Security
Act 2013 is explicit in stipulating that
the right and duty to appoint the chair
of the committee lie with the members of
the committee that right used to be that
of the prime minister but it was
specifically in terms through statute
taken away if the Prime Minister didn't
know the provisions of the 2013 justice
and Security Act that is itself Colin
frankly disturbing if he did know the
contents and provisions of the 2013
justice and Security Act but chose
nevertheless to interfere in this albeit
clumsy and ham-fisted but rather at
Hoani and fashion that is truly
disgraceful I use my words knowingly and
advisedly the government has made a
complete
exhibition of itself in the matter
Julian Lewis is as you rightly say a
close friend of mine I have known him
for nearly 37 years he's the only
Conservative member of the House with
previous experience of serving on the
committee and he is eminently
well-qualified to chair it there is
frankly no argument or debate to be had
about that matter
and it is highly significant that he
commanded the support of opposition
members the government ought to know
when it's defeated and when it looks
frankly a bit foolish but for those
people who don't necessarily fully
understand the way select committees
work is it the case of the chair of a
select committee like that it's not a
select committee forgive me it's not
it's not a Security Committee
well the chairmanship of the
intelligence and Select Committee
Intelligence and Security Committee has
autonomy that means that chair is
endowed with powers that might make
trouble for the government well the
importance of the committee is that it
is there to scrutinize the work of the
intelligence services and it is to be
independent of government so it's not a
question of whether it's making trouble
for the government it is a question of
whether the committee is discharging its
responsibility to exercise scrutiny and
oversight I'm sure nobody Collinwood
seriously suggests that Julian Lewis
whose track record in this field is very
long-established is somehow unreliable
doesn't have the national interest at
heart or lacks a grasp of the issues
none of those things is true he is
spectacularly well-qualified he enjoys
support across the house the government
was in breach of the statute in seeking
to interfere and frankly to accuse
Julian of what essentially the
government is accusing him of namely a
lack of integrity and an impropriety is
frankly outrageous he has 23 years
service in the house he's a highly
dedicated member he knows the issues and
with all due respect to Chris Grayling
who was obviously the government's
favorite choice and against whom I have
no personal grudge he was always very
courteous to me when he was leader of
the house Chris Grayling manifestly was
not qualified to discharge the
responsibility
absolutely not first of all he knows
absolutely nothing in particular about
intelligence and security and secondly
nice chat though Chris Grayling is his
whole track record shows that anything
he touches turns to disaster he is
congenitally incapable of seeing a
problem without making it very
considerably worse so on those two
grounds I can well see why members of
the committee they thought to themselves
no Julian is the proper person to have
chairing this committee that is what
they did think is not for the government
to interfere in the choice of members of
parliament in this matter and frankly
the government and the Prime Minister
ought to know when they're beaten and
they ought to back off if they think
they're going to intimidate or brutalize
Julian Lewis can I just offer the
government grips a word of friendly
advice
I've known Julian for more than 35 years
they've picked on the wrong man here
they're not gonna outdo him he's quicker
he's sharper he's brighter and he is a
person of unimpeachable integrity who
will serve the committee and the House
of Commons with distinction